alors je voulais vous montrer un
reportage on va regarder ensemble sur
dix se dit qu'il va vous intéresser par
ce qu'est ce que le champagne français
est toujours aussi prisé aux états unis
va précisément c'est la question que
nous avons posée à notre envoyé spécial
permanent à new york paul nahon voici ce
reportage la bataille du champagne est
l'une des plus vieilles bataille que se
livrent les connaisseurs champagne
français contre champagne californien le
champagne français le plus cher 150
francs environ la bouteille
le champagne california moins cher moins
apprécié malgré les énormes progrès
réalisés par les vignerons de la côte
ouest à new york
ce seul magasin vend 600 bouteilles de
champagne par mois véronique un client
rentre dans votre magasin et achètent du
champagne prend du champagne américaine
du champagne français il tente d antenne
français
pour quelles raisons qu'est ce qu'ils
considèrent américain la qualité la
tradition
ce résultat est dû d'abord à la qualité
du vin français mais aussi à l'action du
bureau du champagne aux états unis ce
bureau représente toutes les marques les
négociants et les vignerons français qui
exporte en amérique 15 millions de
bouteilles par an ce bureau défend
l'appellation champagne
le label français
en europe ne peut être appelé champagne
peut-être étiquetté champagne que les
vins qui sont produits dans la région
champenoise à savoir que les allemands
appellent leurs mousseux sectes les
italiens à l'appel asti spumante et ses
actes et rallie si on a fait le champion
la veille champagne en décembre où ça
c'est embêtant mais c'est également
totalement intéressant de c'est une des
raisons pour les cadets sont ici il n'y
a qu'un chant c'est le champagne de
france le reste du moose c'est à dire
quelle différence faites vous entre le
moose le champagne l'appellation
chantait america ne sera jamais sérieux
concurrent du chanteur anglais jeunes
tu oses à votre santé